I've been covering finance for nearly a
decade and I've written about some wild
stuff but there's no issue I've covered
that causes more stress in people's
lives than student loans some one in six
American adults has a student loan a
quarter of them are having trouble
paying it back and it's no wonder it's a
horribly and needlessly complicated
system it's not easy to make sense of
your finances I'm shaking the cirrie
poor and I want to meet people with an
obsession to beat the system
and never leave money on the table
[Music]
consider this the feds offer borrowers
about six ways to get their loans
forgiven one of the most prominent ways
taking a public service job after
college has a 99% rejection rate
licensed clinical social worker Michael
Mitchell is part of the 1% he's one of
the first to make it through the federal
public service loan forgiveness program
which started in 2007 I visited his
office in Manhattan to find out how so
by the time I got through this whole
process it and got the forgiveness it
was actually a hundred and seventy
thousand Wow I just remember seeing my
net worth one day like you know going
from here to here
did you like call anyone you tell anyone
I spoke with my best friend we popped
open a bottle of champagne really in
2007 Congress created public service
loan forgiveness the pitch for borrowers
was you spend 10 years as a nurse police
officer basically work for a government
agency or a non-profit and after 12
on-time payments a year for a decade
whatever's left of your debt is wiped
away it's a huge benefit available to
about 1/4 of all Americans with the job
I downloaded the the law and I read it I
had been a proofreader before so I'm
just you know somebody who's very
detail-oriented and you know at this
point it was probably a hundred and
thirty hundred and forty thousand
dollars that I owed because it just kept
growing even though I was already paying
loan payments at that point so your
balance was shooting up so my balance
was continuing to creep up right there
was a whole group of people
luckily myself not included who were
told when filing these forms that they
did work in eligible employment and then
maybe four years through the process it
didn't count yeah it didn't count they
did they backtracked on that it sounds
simple when you just kind of toss it off
of like oh yeah you work ten years and
not-for-profit and your loans are
forgiven but there's a lot of nuance to
it how often did you call your loan
servicer to talk about this by the end I
was calling them probably
every other day Wow what public service
isn't the only way to get your student
debt forgiven you can die for example
sorry it's a bit grim but it is true or
if you're totally disabled or so
destitute that you'll never be able to
afford your payments the feds will
forgive your loans then too the other
big waist enrolling plants entire
monthly payments to your income like
Michael did while he was in the public
service plan
here's Bloomberg reporter Janet Lauren
on how borrowers can pay less on their
loans caution there's a warning coming
there are programs called income-based
repayment and students can qualify based
on what they're making you also have to
be mindful that the interest is going to
be accruing there's a scary term called
negative amortization and that means
even though you may not be making a
payment or making a small payment the
total balance of your loan is continuing
to grow thanks Janet
let's look at the scary math Janet just
laid out imagine you make 45 grand a
year
Ennio 50 grand at 6% interest now you
could try to pay it off over 10 years by
making monthly payments of about 550
bucks or you could opt into the income
based plan and pay as little as 220
month but consider this
under the first option your total
payments including interest would come
out to about 66 grand under the second
because of all that interest and because
you'd be paying over about twice the
amount of time you pay more than 92
grand student loans can have a really
steep interest rates and if you can
afford it you'd be better off paying a
bit more than required because it'd be a
smart way to avoid paying unnecessary
interest
remember generally whatever interest you
don't pay just gets added to your total
balance a lot of people are paying
interest on interest it's stressful but
meeting stress head-on can feel good
give the old college try
you